♪♪
Hey, everybody. I'm just gonna
get started right away.
Japan does have lawns.
So here's the thing.
[ Laughter ]
I don't even remember the joke,
but all of a sudden,
a lot of commenters are telling
me, "Japan doesn't have lawns."
So I come out here,
I correct myself,
and now everybody's saying,
"Dude, you're crazy.
Japan does have lawns."
Look. You guys figure it out.
I've never been there.
I want to go.
It's on my bucket list.
But this is the last
I'm gonna say about it.
We talked once again
about the difference
in the spelling of "psych."
When you say to someone,
"Psych!
is it spelled P-S-Y-C-H
or is it spelled S-I-K-E?
Which is how we spelled it
a couple weeks ago
at this point in the broadcast.
People feel very strongly
that the correct spelling
is P-S-Y-C-H and not S-I-K-E.
Also, I didn't know this.
"Sike" is a small stream.
You guys want to see a picture
of a small stream?
[ Laughter ]
Psych.
Um, I said that Biden
tried to talk to a turkey
when he was pardoning
the turkeys.
A bunch of you said,
"No. He did."
[ Laughter ]
He maybe tried to have
a conversation,
but he definitely
talked to the turkey.
Apologies.
Also, someone said, "Fauci
is two years older than Biden.
Why don't you make fun of him
for being old?"
It's really just, I guess,
the fact that Fauci never
kind of just wandered off.
[ Laughter ]
Fauci looks great for his age.
And remember -- it's easy to
forget he had to stand on stage
when Donald Trump
tried to do science.
That'll age a person.
Hey, another thing I just
want to say in general
as I look back on the pandemic.
Look, did everybody get it right
from the beginning?
Did Fauci make zero mistakes?
Absolutely not.
It's, you know, a pandemic.
You're having to make decisions
quick in real time.
I think, overall, job well done.
But this is something
I really want to hammer home.
Just because a doctor
makes a mistake
doesn't mean
you're the doctor now.
Oh, so, this is interesting.
We did a "Closer Look"
where we talked about
MyPillow
and Mike Lindell's pillow,
and there was a sound effect
that played
when I dropped the pillow
that was very late.
And I said,
"That's the problem of
having a sound guy
who's in Australia."
But then a bunch of you pointed
out Australia is ahead of us.
So if he was there,
the sound effect would be early.
So it would have been like this.
[ Clang! ]
[ Laughter ]
Alright.
We talked about Johnny Bananas.
We didn't overdo it.
[ Laughter ]
We talked about how
Johnny Bananas' friends
would often play a mean trick
where they'd set him up
on a blind date.
He'd go to a restaurant.
There'd be a --
There'd be a monkey in lipstick.
Well, we showed a picture.
Once again --
And this is the problem
we've been getting in --
year-long problem --
which is we showed
a chimpanzee in lipstick,
which is an ape, not a monkey.
We took the photo with a monkey
and then after the fact
found out the monkey
was nonunion.
[ Laughter ]
And in the 11th hour,
the best we could do
was a chimpanzee.
Kenny was the one
who knew the monkey...
Remember? He was like,
"I've seen that monkey before.
Crossing.
Crossed the picket line."
[ Laughter ]
Difference --
monkeys have tails.
That's how you know
the difference
between an ape and a monkey.
And this is a story --
I did not hear it.
I am not friends
with any chimpanzees.
I have a friend who's friends
with chimpanzees.
He told me this story
about this chimpanzee
who's on a date
with another chimpanzee.
And I guess
it's going great, right?
And they go back
to the chimpanzee's apartment,
and the other chimpanzee
goes into the bathroom,
is thinking,
"I'm gonna get it on."
And then the other chimpanzee
comes out, takes off the robe,
and the first chimpanzee
sees the tail.
And that's all you need
to know about...
-♪ About the crying game ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Clang! ]
I was told -- I did this
for "six," and someone said,
"Don't do -- Don't --
That's bad."
I don't know
the right way to do "six."
But there was -- I guess --
I've seen deleted scenes from
"Inglourious Basterds."
You know, 'cause there's
that giveaway scene?
I guess he goes, "Drei Glaesen."
And that's the giveaway
that he's not German.
And I guess in the original
it's, "Drei Glaesen.
And sechs jalapeño poppers."
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
I don't know, guys.
We talked about
President Samberg.
How Obama's a good comedian
but none of the comedians
I know would be good presidents.
And we just showed a picture
of President Samberg,
but he was a little
too neat-looking.
It was like modern Samberg.
I wanted it to look a little bit
more like the Doofy Samberg.
And then we did a lot
of Samberg material.
And I'm, you know --
I bet Andy saw it, right?
I mean, we talked about him
on TV in a "Closer Look."
And if he --
You know, if not him,
certainly you would think
one of his friends would say,
"Hey, I saw you on..."
Let's find out.
[ Voice call ringing ]
Been a while
since we've called Andy.
[ Bee-oop ]
Nope.
Straight to unavailable.
Guess he's doing a spelling bee.
We talked about Flat Earthers
and are there Flat Mooners?
And from what I can tell,
no, there's not
a Flat Mooners Society.
So I organized
and we had our first meeting
because I like the idea
that one of the celestial bodies
would be flat.
I think that's a fun thing
to sit around
with like-minded people
and talk about, right?
Everybody likes the idea
that they live somewhere
where they could walk to a point
and then be like, "Whoa!"
I mean, who wouldn't want that?
Anyway -- And I think Flat
Mooning is off to a great start.
I guess
some Flat Earthers think
the moon is a projection
onto a dome.
Which would work...
But Flat Mooners,
we're off to a great start.
We do hope
to increase our ranks.
And one of the nice things
about Flat Mooners is --
and one of the hard, fast rules
is we're not gonna let it be
a gateway to anti-Semitism!
[ Laughter ]
We're gonna get together.
We're gonna talk about
how the moon's flat
and nothing else!
Okay?
If somebody
all of a sudden says,
"Hey, you know, if you believe
that, I got something..."
We're gonna be like, "No!
Don't you have a game tonight?!
[ Laughter ]
Um, also a lot of people --
Because I said the moon's flat.
They made very juvenile jokes
about how I have a flat ass.
No, sir.
But that did -- You know,
I did want to have
a little bit of body positivity
after I engaged with that.
And you guys remember
when I didn't --
when I wore my tank top.
[ Laughter ]
Some people said, "Oh, that --
I guess that proves Seth
doesn't have any tattoos."
I actually do, but if I know --
And this happens
to a lot of people in showbiz
who get tattoos --
you have to have them covered
with makeup
before you go on stage.
But here's --
If you want to know, I think,
amongst the Jackals,
I'm happy to share.
I do have one tattoo.
There you go.
Hey. Rhaenyra's dragon
is a female dragon. Syrax.
We did say Trump
thought it was a he.
I do think Trump would think
all dragons are boys.
I'm not saying that's --
[ Clang! ]
The worst part is --
in order -- I can't --
It's so hard to tell them
to stop doing it.
[ Laughter ]
To get them to stop now,
I would have had to
call them yesterday.
By the way, someone wrote,
"There are so many awkward
pauses filled
with fake laughter.
It just becomes off-putting.
This show is so hit-or-miss."
Dude...
[ Laughter ]
That was -- Before we decided
on the name "Corrections,"
we were going to call this
"Hit or Miss."
We said Santa Claus
was 2,000 years old.
And a bunch of you who...
I guess think he's a real...
[ Laughter ]
They're like, "No,
he's based on Saint Nick,
who was, like, born in 280 A.D."
And also somebody said,
"If he's 2,000,
the picture you use
at most looks 100."
So we did -- we went
to our graphics department,
who worked really hard.
We're like, "What do you think
a 2,000-year-old Santa
would look like?"
And I think that's...
I think that's...
[ Laughter ]
It's exciting. Holiday movies.
You know, we don't --
our kids don't watch a bunch --
You know, we don't have
a lot of screen time.
But when we travel
for the holidays,
when we're on the plane
going to see their grandparents,
we will let them watch
a holiday film.
And so I've been spending
a lot of time
trying to pick
the perfect holiday film,
and I'm hoping it goes better
than last year
when I flew with my boys.
We decided to watch
"A Charlie Brown Christmas,"
which is a classic film,
endures over the years.
I downloaded it on my iPad.
Sitting with my two sons.
I've got one of them
on either side of me,
set up the iPad
once we take off.
I waited until we took off.
I did not have
my electronic device off --
on, excuse me -- during takeoff.
Because I did that once,
and the plane crashed.
So I didn't...
I'm not gonna make
that mistake again.
[ Laughter ]
So, I have my iPad out,
you know,
on its little stand, and --
I was just --
I don't even know if my --
I'm worried my kids are not
gonna want to watch anything
on a plane again
because the minute it started,
the stewardess ran.
Ran down the aisle and slammed
my iPad face-down.
And we were all like...
And I guess there was
someone on the flight
who was allergic to peanuts.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
I asked Shoemaker --
I asked Shoemaker what his
favorite Christmas movie was,
and he goes, "'The Grinch,'
before he switched!"
[ Laughter ]
Don't get him started
on The Grinch.
He's like, "He didn't have
the guts to finish the job!
He blinked!"
Someone wrote, "I want to meet
the graphics department
to see if they're the way
Seth makes them out to be."
Well, they want
to meet you, too,
and they're down for everything.
I looked at one of their
Tinder profiles recently,
and the only thing it had on it
was "Turn-offs: none."
This breaks my heart.
My mom was here
the last time we did this,
and I was talking about
the French Revolution.
And I said, you know, people --
les personnes.
French for "people."
And everyone on YouTube
is saying,
"You actually said 'poissons.'
Fish.
Which I'm like -- No, I didn't.
I know what I said. I know
poissons. I know personnes.
And then someone basically says,
"And I know you did because
YouTube agrees with me."
They -- You lower-thirded me
"poissons."
Am I not making enough money
for you, YouTube?
I'm genuinely curious.
Allergic to peanuts.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, um, you know,
I originally said --
You know, we were talking
about the French Revolution,
and I said 19th century,
and everybody's like,
"No. 18th century."
But, of course, in "Les Mis,"
which is what
we were talking about,
it was the 19th century,
because what they do in France,
they just keep having them.
There's a lot of them.
And there were uprisings
in 1830, 1832, 1848.
I was referring --
"Les Mis" is about
the July revolution in 1830,
and that was the one
where I was talking about
how they stacked up
all the furniture,
and that was the most --
I was making the argument
that was the most furniture
that was ever stacked
in an armed conflict.
But I was corrected.
The most furniture stacked
in an armed conflict...
Never mind. I feel like --
I feel like this crowd today
isn't reacting to the jokes
the way they deserve.
[ Laughter ]
The war that had
the most furniture stacking
took place
in the Ottoman Empire!
[ Laughter ]
Hey, we -- I kind of --
I threw a little shade
to intermittent fasting
last week.
A lot of you said
intermittent fasting
has done wonders for you
and has helped
your health problems.
And so I want to apologize
for saying
that intermittent fasting
is a diet that doesn't work.
I stand corrected, but maybe be
a bit more intermittent
when you bring it up at parties.
"Teen Wolf."
We talked about Obama,
when he was seven,
trying to decide if vampires
or werewolves were cool.
And a lot of you said --
He referenced "Teen Wolf"
in that argument.
A lot of you said
when he was seven, it was 1968.
"Teen Wolf" hadn't come out yet.
But a lot of you don't know
"Teen Wolf" is not --
is based on a real dude.
Who was on the 1968 --
Which -- Now the math works out
perfectly, Shoemaker.
Was on the 1968 US Men's
Olympic basketball team.
I think I know which one he is.
I'm trying to...
There he is.
Hey, we had this art card --
Not art card. We had this art.
And, um...
At this point in the broadcast.
And we said Waldo's in it.
And we asked you to pause it
and look for stuff and...
A bunch of you said
Waldo's not in it.
Well, I will tell you now
that Waldo is in it.
A very little bit of Waldo
is in it.
And if you can find it...
circle it...
and mail it in to us.
You get nothing!
[ Laughter ]
I forgot --
This came in a while ago.
Lovely letter
from a man named Phil.
Um...
He asked his son
to design a prototype
for the Corrections mug
while we were waiting for ours.
So this was
this summer actually.
"My kid worked very hard
and said that they drew
your face very accurately.
I'll be happy to send people
at NBC the file with the design
if you decide
to mass-produce this."
Here is their Corrections mug.
[ Laughter ]
And we do appreciate
your son's hard work,
and we're gonna
send him something --
a cease-and-desist letter.
[ Laughter ]
You guys.
I talked about the fact
that I was going to --
I felt bad that I put us
in a legal situation
where all the foreign Jackals
who sent in postcards
were then going to--
Just gonna check real quick
if Samberg's said anything.
And it's a hard "no."
Um, let me see.
You guys aren't -- You --
Anybody have anything to do?
Great.
The thing --
I'm kind of dragging it out
because we've got
our holiday party tonight.
And I'm gonna try to keep the
staff here as long as possible,
because I don't want them
to get too [bleep] up.
[ Laughter ]
So I said I didn't want NBC
to have to pay for the mugs.
I'll pay for the mugs.
Well, everybody was like,
"Oh, my God, Seth. So great."
I do want to stress NBC said,
"We're going to pay
for the mugs."
But I felt bad
because it was my fault.
So I decided,
whatever the total was,
I would take
that amount of money
and I would give it
to a charity.
That way,
NBC is paying for the mugs.
I'm giving the money, the same
amount of money to the charity.
So I looked around,
did some research,
and I'm happy to announce
that I'm writing a check
to an organization that I think
could really use the money.
NBC.
[ Laughter ]
You know what
the burden is there.
They have a matching program.
[ Laughter ]
Well...
[ Buzzes lips ]
[ Laughter ]
Still over an hour to the party.
[Bleep]
Aah!
AAH!
I think I did it all.
[ Clang! ]
[ Laughter ]
Go home!
Does anybody ever do that?
Should that be my new sign-off?
[ Laughter ]
What did Tracey Ullman do?
Wasn't that it?
"Go home"?
[Bleep].
Still over an hour.
[ Laughter ]
See me next week.